[Musique]
bonsoir mercredi 20 octobre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 60,18 voici les
titres de cette édition
l'ouverture aujourd'hui à versailles du
procès du chantage présumé à la sextape
au préjudice de mathieu valbuena cinq
personnes dont karim benzema
comparaissent devant le tribunal
correctionnel l'audience retransmise par
une agence yvelinoise css prod basée à
plaisir il ya un an samuel patier été
victime de la folie terroristes dans son
ouvrage est exécuté un chien de l'enfer
l'auteur david di nota mènent une contre
enquête sur l'assassinât du professeur
d'histoire géographie de conflans sainte
honorine elle longue interview à suivre
dans ce journal et puis 76 jeunes vont
célébrer l'amitié franco allemand grâce
à une série de concerts dans les deux
pays ces musiciens viennent du
conservatoire à rayonnement régional de
versailles grand parc et de l' orchestre
des jeunes de la région de berlin nous
avons pu les suivre lors de répétitions
tout à l'heure également direction saint
germain en laye la maison de claude
debussy va fermer le 31 octobre prochain
près de deux ans de travaux pour cette
bâtisse du xviie siècle afin qu'elles
connaissent une nouvelle jeunesse
[Musique]
l actualité du jour dans les yvelines
avec l'ouverture de ce procès le procès
dit de la sextape qui s'est ouvert ce
mercredi devant le tribunal
correctionnel de versailles cinq hommes
comparaissent dans cette affaire et de
chantage au préjudice du footballeur
mathieu valbuena l'audience doit durer
jusqu'à vendredi sur le banc des accusés
notamment l'international français karim
benzema poursuivi pour complicité de
tentative de chantage sur son ex
coéquipier en sélection est lors d'un
rassemblement des bleus en octobre 2015
le joueur du real madrid est soupçonné
d'avoir incité mathieu valbuena a payé
une rançon l'objectif éviter la
diffusion publique d'une vidéo intime à
caractère sexuel dans ce tracé
stratagème derrière ce stratagème de
maître chanteur accusé de tentative de
chantage et l'un d'eux également pour
abus de confiance et deux autres
personnes sont poursuivies dans cette
affaire un mathieu valbuena est lui bien
présent pour ce procès karim benzema
représenté par ses avocats est le joueur
de 33 ans risque cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et jusqu'à 70 mille
euros damende un procès médiatique
retransmis en direct au tribunal de
versailles pour les journalistes
présents et derrière cette
retransmission lagence 2 production css
prod basse est basée à plaisir à bixente
marc censi steban et patrick jacques de
dixmude ont pu suivre la préparation et
l'installation du matériel pour le
procès
quatre caméras sur des plans fixes c'est
le dispositif utilisé par l'agencé ace
prod pour couvrir le procès du chantage
présumé à la sextape du footballeur
mathieu valbuena ou cinq personnes dont
un autre international français karim
benzema sont appelés à comparaître du 20
au 22 octobre une retransmission
installé depuis la veille mais - le
procès de karim benzema s'ouvre à
versailles donc nous on est mobilisé on
est deux à être mobilisés pendant trois
jours du début du procès jusqu'au
verdict en fait et après on a tout la
désinstallation aussi pour que ballan
dit les gens puissent travailler sans
avoir toutes ces caméras et essai télé
un procès dit médiatique les caméras
sont installées pour permettre une
retransmission en direct dans une salle
annexe composé de journalistes et toute
personne souhaitant il a assisté en fait
on n'a pas le droit de faire de la
réalisation dessus parce qu'il faut
surtout pas dénaturé en fait ce qui se
dit et c'est vraiment juste pour repart
comme si les gens étaient dans la salle
en fait pour cette affaire les caméras
vous restez fixe en revanche pour une
autre catégorie de procès une
réalisation et mise en place il ya une
différence avec les procès historique
par exemple on couvre en ce moment v13
donc le procès du bataclan dans ce cadre
là par contre qu'à une réalisation on
est avec un peu plus de caméras ya huit
caméras la règle de base en général on
met à l'image la personne qui parle on
essaye de limiter les plans d' écoute et
plans de réaction cette prod retransmet
les audiences dans le cadre d'un
partenariat avec le ministère de la
justice ça fait maintenant ça doit faire
six ans qu'on couvre les pros c'est donc
presque tous les procès historique alors
c'est quoi les procès historique pas ya
effectivement le celui en ce moment
c'est v13 avant il y avait le procès de
charlie hebdo encore avant on a fait les
procès sur le génocide rwandais et après
au niveau partie médiatique ont amené à
faire des et procès d'un tueur en série
2 ou de stars alors là il ya benzema on
a fait le procès à l'idée en tant que
prestataire audiovisuel du ministère il
arrive à lagence de couvrir parfois cinq
procès en même temps à travers la france
la société est composée de huit salariés
permanents est une quarantaine
d'intermittent
voilà pour ce procès qui va donc durer
jusqu'à vendredi au chapitre judiciaire
toujours la faire julie connaît une
nouvelle étape à la cour d'appel de
versailles julie c'est le pseudonyme de
cette jeune femme et dont la famille
accuse des pompiers de paris de l'avoir
violée à son domicile alors qu'elle
était mineure et suivait un traitement
médical
médicamenteux lourd en 2010 trois
pompiers avaient été mises en examen
pour viols avant que les faits ne soient
requalifiés en atteintes sexuelles sans
violence contrainte menace est ni
surprise sur mineur de 15 ans par
plusieurs personnes une requalification
contestée par la jeune femme et sa
famille devant la cour de cassation qui
les avait déboutés en mars dernier mais
la juridiction a cassé deux éléments qui
sont donc étudiés depuis hier mardi par
la cour d'appel de versailles est ce que
les atteintes sexuelles présumées du
principal accusé ont été plus longues
est ce que d'autres pompiers que les
trois déjà mises en cause pourraient
être concernés par des faits de
corruption de mineurs les magistrats
vont donc se pencher sur ces deux
questions
le délibéré de la cour d'appel sera
rendue le 1er février 2022 par ailleurs
la mère de julia a déposé plainte avec
constitution de partie civile pour viol
et corruption de mineure contre 17
pompiers qui n'ont pas été mises en
examen et indique aussi avoir déposé un
recours devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme nous vous en parlions
lundi différentes commémorations se sont
tenues samedi dernier en mémoire de
samuel pâti comme ici à conflans sainte
honorine la ville où enseigner le
professeur d'histoire-géographie tué
pour avoir montré les caricatures du
prophète mahomet un libre géant sur la
liberté d'expression a été dévoilée au
cours des commémorations et un an après
le drame le romancier à david di nota
publie ce livre j'ai exécuté un chien de
l'enfer rapport sur l'assassinât de
samuel pâtissent est aux éditions du
cherche midi une contre-enquête sur
l'accumulation des événements qui ont
conduit le terroriste a visé à
l'enseignant david di nota revient sur
cet engrenage dans un entretien avec
patrice carmouze long extrait on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour la
suite de ce journal la contradiction qui
est au coeur de mon lit bras c'est le
fait que cette on a demandé à sam elle
pâtit de s'excuser pour une rumeur créé
par une élève qui n'était pas dans la
classe comme si c'était lui qui est
comme si c'était la victime de la rumeur
qui devait alors en quelque sorte
s'excuser de la rumeur qui le calomniait
je rappelle simplement pour la clarté le
contenu de cette rumeur qui est
extrêmement grave qui consistait à dire
que sa mère pattie avait exclu les
musulmans les élèves musulmans de sa
classe parce que musulman donc cette
rumeur qui faisait de sa mère pattie un
islamophobe va évidemment créer une
dynamique infernale et mon livre
consiste à décrire décrypter décortiqué
l'attitude de l'éducation nationale face
à ce que les anglais appellent un
testing c'est à dire une façon quand les
islamistes de tester vraiment une
structure pour voir si elle craque et
comment elle peut craquer alors alors
essayons de ce tir de da les plus plus
haut foreuse dans ce que vous démontrez
il ya bien cette notion doerig mais qui
existe c'est le d'abord pas de vagues
oui bien sûr bien sûr ce qui est arrivé
à sa mère pattie je dirais que c'est la
face tragique visible de l'iceberg mais
cette
transaction qui fait que le professeur
est toujours
la variable d'ajustement lorsqu'il ya un
litige toujours ce que j'appelle moi le
fautif idéal c'est un long processus qui
vient de très loin donc effectivement
c'est inscrit dans cette danse est
longue tradition malheureuse de
l'éducation nationale et
samuel pâtit évidemment a été la victime
de ce processus là et si on va plus loin
encore au site est d'ailleurs les des
textes officiels de l'éducation
nationale oui un qui disent souvent les
professeurs doivent établir un lien de
confiance oui avec les élèves ces
cétacés et sans dire quand on y
réfléchit impasse mais mais tout à fait
le bleu bleu propos d'un professeur
c'est d'enseigner c'est d'apprendre vous
avez tout à fait raison et je dirais que
c'est mais c'est pire que ça c'est qu'en
fait c'est un nouveau jeu disciplinaire
ou celui qui juge le bon comportement du
professeur c'est l'élève donc si vous
voulez et ça c'est un carnet très
concrètement ça paraît très abstrait
dilemme sa pédagogiquement mais ça c'est
un carnet très
concrètement par si vous prenez
l'accusation qui a été adressé par sa
hiérarchie qui est qu'est-ce qu'on lui a
reprochées au moment même où il était la
victime d'une cabale d'islamistes a
orchestré par un fichier s abdel hakim
sefrioui
qu'est-ce qu'on lui a reprochées on lui
a reproché il faut reprendre les termes
d'avoir froissé ses élèves donc en
quelque sorte c'est l'élève le ressenti
mais non il faut aller plus loin même le
ressenti religieux de l'élève qui
détermine le bon ou le mauvais
comportement d'un professeur laïque vous
voyez l'aberration pédagogique que ça
représente mais derrière cette ab gage à
aberration il y a un vrai enjeu
politique évidemment et on va y revenir
mais c'est en effet cette atmosphère qui
explique neil explicable nouveau c'est à
dire qu on est concerné et l'éducation
nationale et les islamistes et les
terroristes vont prendre au sérieux le
bon sens de cet élève à mai mais c'est
tout et c'est toute l'horreur de la
chose je dirais c'est que le paradoxe si
vous voulez du référent laïcité c'est
qu'ils confirmaient la thèse de l'élève
qui n'était pas dans la classe et qui
dit qu'il a offensés tous ces élèves et
il infirme le témoignage des élèves qui
étaient dans la classe qu'ils disent
mais pas du tout il ya une très bonne
ambiance et c'est donc ça c'est le
paradoxe qui est au coeur de mon enquête
alors autre chose que vous montrez qui
est assez effarant c'est que en effet il
ya des plaintes de parents d'élèves qui
disent des élèves musulmans ont fait
l'objet d'un traitement raciste mais
pire encore il ya des collègues
qui disent ne peut pas traiter des
enfants comme ça parce qu'ils ont une
religion une autre religion que la
religion musulmane c'est ça c'est ça
tout le monde parle alors personne ne
s'est pas sur deux sur un mensonge c'est
exactement ça alors il faut pas
généraliser certains collègues voilà ça
mais c'est vrai que parmi toutes les
accusations auxquelles sa mère pattie
elle a dû faire face celle d'une l'une
des plus douloureuses a certainement été
l'accusation de deux collègues qui sans
vérifier le contenu de la rumeur
sont montés sur leurs grands chevaux et
ont commencé à condamner moralement le
professeur pâtit alors même que la
première des choses c'était de savoir si
c'était vrai ou faux et au fond ça
accentuer encore le climat de solitude
construite administrativement de samuel
paty et on est dans ce que vous appelez
l'irs le ravage de la suspicion de la
présomption de culpabilité parce que
c'est ça c'est exactement ça la rumeur
porte sur une accusation d' islamophobie
et
elle a été renforcée
tragiquement par les différents acteurs
et quand j'ai des différences et bien
des acteurs qui ont des rôles différents
c'est à dire il ya l'administration et à
l'accusatrice c'est-à-dire l'élève via
le rôle des islamistes qui a le rôle des
parents tout ça il faut leur est
constitué mais tout a été dans le même
sens pour accuser un homme innocent la
principale me demande d'ailleurs de
faire des excuses et d'ailleurs il le
fait c'est ce qui est la preuve qu'il ne
paraissait pas jusqu'au bout d'extraits
liste au contraire c'est pas du tout au
contraire même c'est tout le contraire
ce quelqu'un qui voulait absolument bien
faire son travail c'est je pense que le
mot qui le caractérise le mieux je
répète toujours cette expression de
spinoza king qui veut que je trouve très
belle probité un signe je pense qu'il a
simplement fait preuve d'une très grande
probité et que son geste de prévenance
s'est retourné a été construit après
coup par des islamistes en
comment dirais-je en gestes d'accuser
comment dire une stigmatisation en
stigmatisation raciste envers les
musulmans ce qui est évidemment une âme
en songe et on tait mais qui a été
répandue sur la toile avec les
conséquences que l'on connaît il à dire
un certain sens de l'humour parce qu il
divo l'année prochaine je parlerai de la
la censure d'internet en chine comme ça
on voit on ira pas et vous raconter
d'ailleurs que l'année précédente il
avait parlé des caricatures de jésus et
ça devait poser occasionnels strictement
aucun problème mais je vous avez
absolument raison de parler de cette
plaisanterie parce que vous savez les
plaisanteries en toujours un rôle
capital c'est elle qui désigne
véritablement les rapports de pouvoir
lorsqu'on envoie son rapport à son
lorsqu'on lui en
dépêche sur place un référent laïcité
se mêlent pas tiqué beaucoup moins naïf
qu'on a essayé de le faire croire
comprends très bien la fonction de son
avenir en effet cette plaque qui
consiste à dire ok je parlerai plus des
caricatures de charlie hebdo je parlerai
l'année prochaine de la censure en chine
c'était évidemment une façon de dire je
sais très bien ce que vous êtes en train
de faire il est à la fois très lucide
sur la cabale des islamistes est qu'il
nomme nommément 1 c'est quelqu'un qui
nomme les choses donc il dit les
islamistes locaux donc qui la cabale des
socialistes pour perturber son cours sur
la liberté d'expression et puis il est
aussi très lucide sur le rôle pour le
moins ambivalents de son
d'administration qui l'accusent au
moment même où ils auraient besoin
d'être défendue alors continuons sur
cette administration parce que ça c'est
absolument presque incroyable ya donc
les blondes a parlé des parents d'élèves
on va parler de quelques quelques
collègues mais il ya pire que ça
se sert de ce faux témoignage
l'inspection une inspection qui va dire
qui reprend la thèse du mensonge en
disant voilà il a ils auront plus le
seul lien de confiance avec les avec les
élèves là c'est tout de même très c'est
presque une seule reprise allez dire ça
va fort parce que et dit oui il s'en est
pas aperçu un s'était pas aperçu ma
femme voilà il s'est mal conduit c'est
ça exactement vous avez parfaitement
compris le livre est bien vu la boucle
que je décris c'est au fond vous avez
donc la situation quelqu'un qui est pris
en chasse par des islamistes et un
référent laïcité qui confirme la thèse
de l'élève qui n'est pas dans la classe
donc qu'il aurait effectivement froisser
ses élèves qui est une thèse p.déj
pédagogiquement absurde mais qui va être
c'est ça qui est incroyable qui va être
validées par le rapport de l'inspection
générale donc l'instruction générale
reprend la thèse du référent laïcité
donc je dirais presque validé
somnambulique mans sans se rendre compte
de la contradiction pédagogique que ça
représente parce que si effectivement
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure le
comportement d'un professeur dépend de
la sensibilité religieuse de ses élèves
il n'y a pas d'enseignement light
possible donc l'inspection générale
reprend somnambule comment la thèse du
référent laïcité qui en plus se repose
sur un témoignage qui est celle de
l'élève qui dit pas dans la classe
entente en tout cas confirment ce faux
témoignage et va être pris sauve nom
publiquement par l'éducation nationale
puisque l'éducation nationale va
s'appuyer sur ce rapport donc vous avez
une boucle incroyable où personne ne
s'aperçoit 1 que la thèse initiale est
faux c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas froisser
ses élèves et 2 que le fait de lui
reprocher sa est une contradiction
pédagogique donc là on est vraiment dans
l'absurdité la plus la plus profonde
s'il n'y avait pas eu ce drame terrible
qui la décapitation la peine de mort
quoi telle qu'on la voit le pratiquer
pratiquer
ça serait il est accusé d'avoir diffusé
des dd des images pornographiques de ses
élèves et objets des récents expliqué au
commissariat et c'est d'ailleurs vous
l'avouer c'est le 13 octobre là où c'est
une scène capitale qui bizarrement
n'apparaît pas dans le rapport houssam
elle pâtit dis très clairement je n'ai
commis aucune infraction dans l'exercice
de mes fonctions
c'est vous dire que lorsque le référent
laïcité cei absolument dû faire
reconnaître une erreur donc une chose
fausse à savoir qu'il aurait offensé ses
élèves ben voilà ça n'a pas marché
samuel pâtit reste tout à fait prob par
rapport à sa démarche et c'est très
important de rappeler ses mots à lui
parce que dans le rapport tout est
toujours rapportés au style indirect
si la dirai que c'est un site très
confortable notamment veut dire sur un
propos qui est très important dans votre
livre que ce que vous écrivez vous dit
samuel patiner pas morts pour la liberté
d'expression il est mort de
l'antiracisme islamistes oui je voudrais
préciser ce point ccc être c'est un
point important ce important pour vous
ce n'est pas un martyr il n'a pas voulu
mourir pour la liberté d'expression et
je crois qu'il faut se tenir à distance
dessous c'est sous ce discours martirio
logique auquel on a eu droit lors de la
cérémonie officielle je crois qu'il faut
il faut il faut fuir l'émotionnel pour
rester dans l'analyse et ou alors le
symbolique plus qui t'a pas beaucoup
d'importance
l'analyse nous apporte à
démontrer que ce qui s'est passé en
réalité quelle a été la posture
victimaire des islamistes c'est de dire
on nous a traités vous savez il ya une
phrase incroyable quand sefrioui dit si
on avait été juif on nous a reçus tout
de suite on nous aura pas fait attendre
un petit collège reçu par la principale
et le bail il battu voilà donc vous avez
le victimise j'avais l'antisémitisme
très présent et puis alors cette logique
toujours qui consiste à dire et puis
bien sûr la confession j'allais presque
oublié l'essentiel qui est la vie la
vidéo de l'élève qui a menti et qui se
présente vraiment comme la victime on ne
nous traitent pas nous musulmans comme
les autres en fait dit elle donc là vous
avez bien une posture victimaire qui va
comment dirais-je précipité l'engrenage
idéologiquement sais pas si c'est pas un
fait divers c'est un c'est un engrenage
qui s'inscrit dans un dans un
environnement idéologique très
particulier où le victimise a un rôle
très important
vous citez la formule de jeu n'est pas
le djihadisme d'atmosphère qui est
présent dans l'enseignement dans
l'université notamment oui ça ça aussi
c'est oui vous pensez que c'est très
présent mais c'est extrêmement important
ce concept est extrêmement important
pour comprendre la responsabilité de ce
que faisait ebrahim
c&c free wheels est à dire vous laisser
courir une rumeur
sans vous engager directement vous
salissez le nom d'un homme et puis vous
attendez que quelqu'un passe à l'action
on peut pas nécessaire à utiliser ce
terme on peut pas utiliser l'accusation
d' islamophobie innocemment ça n'est pas
possible on sait que cette accusation
tue on en a la preuve
peut-être une dernière question qu'on
n'ose à peine posé parce que je vous en
prie et aime sauter maison les mais
est-ce que
est ce que la mort de samuel partie a
servi à quelque chose eh bien écoutez là
encore on revient en fait à la première
question je dirais qu'il y a deux
possibilités
il ya une possibilité une plantation
très forte du point de vue de
l'éducation nationale de tourner la page
pour oublier les circonstances exactes
et la responsabilité directe de
l'administration dans la non protection
de
du professeur pâtit et puis il y a aussi
peut-être je l'espère la possibilité de
méditer ce qui s'est passé pour que un
autre professeur ne passe pas par le
même cauchemar le même enfer mais ça ça
suppose qu'on décrive honnêtement le
plus précisément possible ce qui est ce
qui s'est véritablement déroulé est ce
ce que j'ai essayé de faire dans mon
livre voilà pour cet extrait d'un
entretien plus long il sera à retrouver
en intégralité dès demain soir jeudi sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile
[Musique]
la suite de notre journal avec cette
célébration de la paix et de l'amitié
franco-allemande 76 jeunes du musiciens
du conservatoire à rayonnement régional
de versailles grand parc mais aussi de
l' orchestre des jeunes de la région de
berlin seront en concert les 21 et 22
octobre deux dates en région parisienne
avant de partir en tournée en allemagne
mélanie pau qui a suivi les répétitions
à versailles
[Musique]
pour ce concert symphonique le chef
mickaël cousteau a souhaité partir du
son pour aller au clair si pièces sont
prévus au programme dont deux composés
par des femmes est une création de 2020
ciné jean baptiste robin à l'origine on
devait faire la neuvième de beethoven
mais en raison de la pandémie on n'a pas
pu la faire parce que c'est trop
dangereux de faire chanter des coeurs et
notamment en allemagne et donc on l'a
remplacé par la cinquième de beethoven
mais toutes les deux font le même chemin
on sait aussi les 75 ans de paix
puisqu'on est dans un message de
réconciliation
franco allemande mais aussi des oeuvres
qui ont été choisis pour être à bord
d'un triptyque ni sous la baguette du
chef d'orchestre près de 80 musiciens
français et allemands tous de moins de
30 ans ils travaillent ensemble depuis
une semaine j'ai une approche différente
parce que on n'a pas la même approche
de leur caisse soit chez les allemands
chez les français les français ont
tendance à être peut-être plus soliste
que
un groupe qui joue un look et les
allemands ont cette culture de leur
caisse très très forte on apprend de
jouer ensemble dans leurs caisses on
apprend à écouter les autres 1 prend
généralement c'est ont fait beaucoup de
la musique pendant une semaine et c'est
très intense et moi je tiens toujours
beaucoup de cette expérience c'est la
deuxième édition de cette alliance entre
le conservatoire à rayonnement régional
et l'orchestré des jeunes de la région
de berlin il ya des parties multiples à
la porte et artistique bien évidemment
du programme choisi avec le chef
d'orchestre michael busto la partie
humaine évidemment de retrouver enfin
une pratique artistique collective et
puis la partie européenne les jeunes
musiciens jouent le 21 octobre à paris
le 22 la versailles six dans la cité
royale le concert est déjà complet l'
orchestre pourra vous enchanter dans la
capitale
on referme ce journal à saint germain en
laye la maison natale de claude debussy
va fermer ses portes au public le 31
octobre elles deux ans de travaux pour
restaurer l'ancienne demeure la rendre
accessible à tous mais aussi revoir la
scénographie dans son intégralité est le
reportage de justin brasier c'était
quelqu'un qui arrivait dans la musique
classique qui bouleverser tout
véritablement
[Musique]
grand compositeur français claude
debussy est né dans cette maison le 22
août 1862 ici ses parents tenaient une
boutique de faïence au rez de chaussée
est logé à l'étagé situé à saint germain
en laye la maison ferme ses portes au
public le 31 octobre pour deux ans pour
cette maison ancienne du xviie siècle
les travaux se sont imposés de même on
voit qu'il ya des infiltrations d'eau on
voit que tout se dégrade petit à petit
et il ya également la question de
l'accessibilité au public la maison
aujourd'hui n'est pas accessible aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
l'escalier du xviie siècle est le seul
accès aujourd'hui dans les étages
objectif des travaux redonner à la
façade son aspect historique implanter
un ascenseur et revoir la muséographie
la muséographie et sera véritablement
revu de fond en comble avec les outils
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est à dire les
outils multimédias qui seront également
présents aux quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
aujourd'hui mais avec l' écoute musicale
beaucoup plus présente
clair de lune vers ypres élus de claude
debussy est considéré aujourd'hui comme
le précurseur de la musique classique
actuel en personnage qui amené quelque
chose de profondément nouveau en fait
sans debussy la musique classique
n'aurait pas connu ce ce changement
c'est vraiment debussy qui fait rentrer
la musique classique dans le xxème
siècle la réouverture est prévue courant
2023 une fois la maison fermée au public
le lieu continuera de vivre avec une
saison musicale hors les murs des
concerts prévus au conservatoire au
musée maurice denis ou encore à l'hôtel
de ville
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant place aux
7,8 société mélanie poké aux manettes
pour parler des gestes écologiques dans
les cantines yvelinoise reste avec nous
c'est dans quelques minutes belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]